welcome to this video I'm not quite sure
why but I'm getting white off of time
again I get white okay um let's see
playing the London system for a change
try to prove that it is not always dull
against dee dee swell from the US okay I
am really want to try for a bit more
than just simple development and play C
493 okay we we are getting to a hybrid
between the sloth and the the groom felt
so but we at age six okay I'd like to
keep my bishop anyway so h3 is useful
the question is what now maybe black is
going to place your heart but this would
be actually no this is to to tempe down
to an online with age six at sea 65 and
one okay 97 this is normally not a great
idea if why it can still um exchange on
d5 simply because the night should be on
c6 in the open sea file structure now my
my rook is very quick undersea file ok
so we be three maybe yeah probably it
does not really have a good reply to
that you can play Queen B 6 but that's
not not very comfortable I'll Queen B 6
I have a good choice i can if i can take
and just claim that this would this porn
weaknesses are a problem i can play
Queen a 3 yeah after that I just got 95
of course
so I'm 92 well that's that's the point
okay okay night should I am take first
on c6 yeah why not I can take on c6 and
then then make sure that that I'm
getting out of the 92 fork so just move
the Queen again 1b3 it might be attacked
at some point so Queen fo also
intensifies the pressure on 161 looks is
six they would have played 92 for cake
so maybe I should if I could have gotten
I could have gone to a 3 as well hmm
maybe this no this is okay this should
be okay okay Queen was so um if I now
take ideas going to take be to wear
don't don't really want that he does not
really have rook c8 because of Bishop a
cig so this is not a problem the
question is what about B 4 B 3 if I go
before he probably has a five so maybe
just be three keep it simple I kept
place you five I forgot about that this
is of course very simple move this was
bad mm know what does c5 have a big big
drawback don't see it at the moment
yeah it's so it's the only move anyway
otherwise i'll just take it yeah well f3
yeah is a move it only looks a bit shaky
f3 if you just move the night I'm fine I
just take it it unhappy with the pawn
yeah but I don't really see the drawback
maybe can I cannot really take on d4 I
just I just take it for I don't see the
compensation yeah maybe you should try a
move like a five or g5 nope ok so I'll
just take it right why should I take g5
and then c5 yeah well i can now again i
can really just take it after 96 hours i
have a look-see six so 96 whoopsie six
should be very clear
maybe you should yeah exactly if I've
could be an idea but Roxy six should be
strong shouldn't sit after he moves the
Queen I can really take e five with the
bishop I don't really see the big big
issue yeah that's very nice for what he
doesn't really have any any any
particular counterplay ah look see one
probably or not yeah Queen should be to
you should go to deform now look Queen
f2 this is unnecessary really why did I
allow that yeah rook c1 idiotic
completely stupid move and now I need to
be a bit a bit cautious
yeah Brooks you want and then back not
great but it's still it still looks very
good okay come on let's let's get rid of
this this night nights are really tricky
so keep keep it simple it's really a
good term a good train of thought keep
it simple okay let's see should I can
just take it right gianluca saying
black resigned yeah a very very
problematic position right of the
opening I mean this is a bit passive and
I really don't know what age six is all
about okay the structure really it might
look harmless to you but it is a problem
because I'm so much quicker on the sea
far um yeah in this position the
computer already gives white an edge off
more than one pawn with simple moves
queen bee three rook FC one and then c7
is the point of entry this is really a
big difference with the night on d 7
instead of c6 if you would have the
knight on c6 here it's much much much
different because I play along the sea
file as soon as far as a factor here it
it really quickly got problematic yeah
after Queen B 6 the trade is a good move
whoopsie seven is good and this is also
a good move attacking a seven not sure
what I would have played okay but after
that 95 was just good take stakes and
here maybe Queen a3 is even more factor
if that's possible covering the C 5
squared still keep this under tech rook
c8 is never an option this is even
winning the exchange the rook is caught
in this crossfire of bishops might yes
really no way to cover that let's say
queen bee 6 for example i can just
improve here Brooksie one Roxie Roxie
two rocks here on it's just a terribly
weak pawn yeah to compass on more than
plus to him and black has absolutely no
camel to play three
very bad position I mean this this keeps
keeps an edge but other one was strong
as well aunty area computer gives a five
as the best drive takes takes and takes
him yeah let's sleep on my white white
should probably win Ian but this is
maybe a better fighting fighting
possibility than the game but still very
bad for blood like okay thanks for
watching